Right now, we've been
seeing a huge increase
from people ordering
stuff off of the dark web.
CUSTOMS OFFICER
1: The dark web is
a criminal flea market anyone
with the internet can access.
There was a big website
back in the day, Silk Road.
My understanding is
that was taken down,
but there are other
versions of it.
CUSTOMS OFFICER 1: You can
purchase drugs, weapons,
stolen credit card numbers,
and virtually anything illegal
on this marketplace.
[urgent music playing]
They can go on the website,
they can create fake IP
addresses, the demand is here.
Anything that you
buy on the dark web
has a potential to be the
most dangerous drug out there.
You might think that
you're buying ecstasy,
and it could be fentanyl.
You don't know what it is.
[urgent music playing]
CHIP: Sprinkles for ice cream.
CHIP (VOICEOVER): We noticed
some anomalies on the X-ray.
Could be coffee, could be pills.
Pills from Spain.
Two packages from
the same sender.
Approximately the same
quantity in each one.
I'm going to have
to take it inside
and use a field test kit.
This is a test kit
for MDMA and ecstasy.
Positive results should be
very dark blue to black.
Dark blue, positive test.
Take it over and weigh it.
[urgent music playing]
CHIP: We've called
HSI, and the agents
will be here shortly
to pick these up for
a possible controlled delivery.
We've seen a number of these
going to numerous locations
throughout the United States.
Some of them going to New York,
some of them going to Vegas.
[buzzing]
HSI OFFICER: Hey Chip,
how are you doing?
CHIP: Got two,
going to New York.
HSI OFFICER: Appreciate
your help, thank you.
CHIP: Anytime.